good morning believe nation today's
message is shut out the distractions
over to you Robert Greene TV go there's
differences and then there's there's not
differences so you know the brain is the
same the brain evolved over the course
of millions of years so I try to make
the point that you know what da Vinci
was going through the process is that
there's a template there and it's the
same because our brains haven't really
changed in an evolutionary sense in four
or five hundred years on the other hand
the circumstances are different and
people now live in a world where there's
many more distractions so it's harder to
do that kind of focus that I was
mentioning so in some ways it's a little
bit harder and the people that I've
interviewed are really good at shutting
out all of the distractions of the world
that's sort of what separates them every
single one of them Paul Graham you know
Paul Graham Paul doesn't have a
smartphone yeah yeah he doesn't spend
time on the Internet
he's extremely focused the woman yoky
Matsuoka she she does all of her writing
with a pen and paper she's not sitting
there day in and day out on the computer
checking her Facebook or Twitter page or
whatever I could go through all of them
that way Steve Jobs is sort of the
ultimate icon of mastery of our era and
he said the only thing that's
differentiated me from everyone else was
my level of focus I could take a problem
and I could focus on it and burrow into
it and everybody else was so distracted
he knew how to close his door get away
from his wife his kids everyone and just
focus so the all of these people have to
overcome the intense distractions in our
world they and they're able to do it on
the other hand what you can get with a
click on the internet with a Google
search
compared to what da Vinci had to do or a
scientist in the 19th or 20th century is
absolutely astounding so what you have
at your fingertips the knowledge the
things that you can connect and learn
about the potential for learning skills
is out of this world so if you're able
to overcome the distracting elements
that are it's I my government I wrote
compared it to if you ever watch a
basketball game and you see the opposing
team shooting free throw and everyone
behind him the stands are all going like
this with those big you know trying to
distract him there's like hundreds of
people that's what the world is like now
you've got thousands of people waving
those things you've got so many
distractions if you're able to overcome
that and be a person that can focus you
have this like wealth of information and
knowledge and ability to acquire skills
that nobody a hundred years ago 20 years
ago could dream about so what do you
think I think it's a really great topic
super important for all of us
entrepreneurs because I mean I can
relate in my life I had this this
productivity peak where I couldn't like
it was a plateau actually where I was
just getting enough stuff done but not
enough to get to the next level and I I
consulted with few books and with Evan
gave me some productivity tips and I
learned that you know when I really want
to get stuff done I gotta shut the phone
off log out of my email accounts shut
down every browser every program that I
don't need to use if I'm using the
computer and just really just go into
like my own little her medical frickin
cocoon know hermetic cocoon and just
focus single tasks focus on the one
thing you need to do shut everything
down and I find that way in the span of
a few hours just focus dedicated on
whatever it is I'm doing I can get so
much done in just a few hours where
normally would have taken me a whole day
for maybe two or three of multitasking
to get the same stuff done and just the
kind of joy I get out of single tasking
when you're and when everything's shut
down it's just you just feel so great
just feels really good you think you
should get a t-shirt the Hermetic I'm in
a hermetic cocoon already you just read
a book about this right
you're one thing you're one thing okay
thing your one thing is a really great
book by Gary Keller about basically
about focusing single tasks focusing
laser beam focus and shutting the
distractions as a part of of it really
great book really great for
entrepreneurs veg school when I get to
the next level I love the message it's
when I can relate to I used to be the
guy who was always responsive and always
playing by other people's agendas I was
a guy who would respond an email within
like 60 seconds you know I used Outlook
back then I had Outlook open all the
time something came in boom instant
reply and people say wow you responded
so quickly thank you so much and I used
to pride myself on that but then I
realized that that behavior was holding
me back from doing anything big anything
great because if you're focused
something creative you're trying to
write a book you're trying to create
videos you're trying to do something
bigger picture you need you need the the
freedom and the space just in your head
to be able to focus on that task and if
you're constantly every 30 seconds being
pinged by an email or a tweet or
Facebook update then you're never
actually going to get the big stuff done
I went now the opposite right like I
check email once a day for my team and
every couple days for general public you
know I don't have a cellphone I don't
use a phone it's other people's agenda
for your time so kind of like I might be
there in the cocoon more than you on
that flap I saw like controversial ideas
but it helps me focus on what I'm
working on at that moment right and and
at first my wife thought you don't have
a cellphone how am I gonna reach you you
know you got to get one but now she's
actually happy because when I'm with her
I'm with her
I'm not checking my email and checking
status updates and you know how many
people are out on the dates and it was
just buried in their phones and so when
I'm doing video I'm doing video when I'm
with my son and with my son when with my
wife with my wife when I'm focusing on
my business I focus on my business and
that helps me be great in all of those
areas at that time instead of being
mediocre everything at once so the
question today today is what are you
gonna do to get your laser focus I like
it leaving the comments below will join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe
and we'll see you again s'more morning
for another shot of espresso so the
question of the day today is how are you
gonna I don't know how am I going so
we'll do you like a Chewbacca in there
service Oh Hayden you have to be careful
mister